you know i think it's that that the
famous line the character max
said in the l word i want to feel whole
i want the outside of me to match the
inside of me
so do you now feel that and what
is that like to walk in that space of
you well it's
it's this interesting uh dichotomy in a
way where on some level it feels just
like the most
miraculous amazing thing and it also was
just sort of
the experience of oh there i am
like oh there i am canadian actor elliot
page
sits down with oprah winfrey on apple tv
pluses the oprah conversation
to speak out about the societal
pressures he faced before coming out as
transgender in december
the 34 year old star recalls one
difficult time in particular
when his manager presented him with
feminine clothing options during a press
tour
the 2010 film inception which led to a
panic attack
we got back to the room and she was like
i have a surprise
and like i already had to wear the dress
had one picked out and i went in and
there were three dresses laid out like
new dresses to maybe see
and i just like
i like i lost it like i got so
it was like a cinematic moment you know
like the kind of like
thing that would be in a movie where you
know
and that night after the premiere and at
the after party i
collapsed and that was something that's
happened frequently in my life usually
corresponding with a panic attack paige
also reveals why he felt it was
important to open up about
undergoing top surgery a procedure
designed to
remove unwanted breast tissue in time
magazine
why did you decide to talk about your
top surgery
in time magazine i wanted to talk about
it
for a couple reasons i wanted to share
with people
just how much it has changed my life
and i want people to know that not only
has it you know been life-changing for
me i do believe it's
life-saving um and it's the case for so
many people
and because there is such an attack on
trans healthcare right now
when already there's such lack of access
or trans people who don't even want to
go to the doctor
what you are hearing from certain
lawmakers
are actual complete and utter
their other lies in terms of what
they're saying about
the health care and the umbrella academy
actor goes on to tell oprah the changes
he hopes to see
with how trans people are portrayed
moving forward
yeah i think you said it well in terms
of just trans people
getting to just be people um versus the
story focusing on
very intense trauma or violence or
uh the idea that there's a
you know mental illness or what have you
um
and new narratives and
what's i think you know so important in
terms of representation
in in front of the camera of course but
equally behind the camera
the writers and the directors and to
continue to tell
to tell more more stories from
the perspective of trans people